So imagine that Kris Medlen from Atlanta Braves is the pitcher.
And Martin Prado from Arizona Diamondbacks is at the bat.
Kris Medlen has the goal of finishing the inning without allowing any runs.
How does Kris Medlen decide on an action? We may conceptualize Medlen's decision
making like the following. Medlen may look at various choices that
are available to him. He may throw a pitch. Or he may choose to walk the batter.
If he walks the batter, then there are additional possibilities that open up.
He'll need to face the next batter. If he chooses to pitch, then he'll have to
decide what kind of ball to throw. A slider, a fast ball, or a curve ball.
If it was a slider, then there is a next set of possibilities open up.
There might be a strike or a ball or a hit or he may just strike the batter out.
Thus, Medlen is setting up a state space. Now, what we just did informally can
be stated formally. So, we can imagine a number of states in the states space.
The state space is a combination of all the states that can be achieved by
applying various combinations of operators, starting from the initial state.
Each state can be described in terms of some features, f1, f2,
there could be more. Each feature can take on some values. For example, v1,
there might be a range of values here. So initially, the picture is at state s0.
And the pitcher wants to assume some state S101. And at a state S101
presumably the pitcher the pitcher's goal has been accomplished. So we may think
as the pitcher's decision making as some kind of a part of its current state to
this particular goal state. This is an abstract space. The pitcher has not yet
made any action. The picture is still thinking. The picture is sitting up
an abstract state space in his mind and exploding that state space.